le premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle se déroule ce dimanche 10
avril 2022 et parmi les candidats on
retrouve emmanuel macron pour la
république en marche marine le pen pour
le rassemblement national jean luc
mélenchon pour la france insoumise
yannick jadot d'europe écologie les
verts anne hidalgo pour le parti
socialiste jean lassalle pour résistons
philippe poutou pour le nouveau parti
anticapitaliste eric zemmour pour
reconquête valérie pécresse pour les
républicains nathalie arthaud avec la
lutte ouvrière nicolas dupont aignan
pour debout la france et puis fabien
roussel du parti communiste français
pour rappel lors de la première élection
présidentielle en 2017 c'est emmanuel
macron qui est arrivé en tête dans les
yvelines avec 28 86 % des votes pour son
parti en marche suivie de près par le
party les républicains représenter en
2017 par françois fillon avec 27,25 %
des suffrages
arrivait ensuite elle apprend ce
insoumise avec 16 65% des voix
représentées par jean luc mélenchon et
puis le front national aujourd'hui
rassemblement national représenté par
marine le pen arrivait en quatrième
position dans le département avec à 12
92 % des votes du côté des électeurs et
yvelinois en 2010 est le taux de votants
dans le département était de 90 34 %
cette année encore beaucoup diebling ont
prévu de se déplacer aux urnes ce
dimanche c'est important de
voter pour donner notre avis
si on veut changer de choses il produit
le pays
c'est important de s'exprimer en plus
d'être un droit c'est un devoir pour moi
surtout dans la situation actuelle je
pense que c'est important d'aller donner
sa voix et de se faire représenter au
niveau du territoire comme je ne sais
plus qui a dit eh bien si on s'occupe
pas de la politique c'est la politique
qui s'occupe de vous donc oui je vais
aller voter comme je vais toujours fait
depuis depuis que j'ai 18 ans un choix
déjà arrêté pour la plupart à trois
jours du premier tour bah je vais voter
parce que j'ai toujours voté et toujours
pour le même parti du routier macro et à
aucun programme
indépendant on doit corriger dès la fin
du dix bonnes choses et bordeaux qui
critique moi je le trouve que je trouve
bien oui mon choix est arrêté et ben
j'ai fait tout simplement en regardant
les programmes les diverses interviews
oui je vais voter parce que j'ai des
convictions et je veux que monsieur
macron parts et j'ai des convictions moi
je vais aller voter pour valérie
pécresse ça clairement c'est un choix de
voter blanc fait pour exprimer mon pote
m'a tant que rencontre le vote blanc
automatiquement
on est toujours hésitant aller voter
mais on ira quand même ce qui mélange un
peu les parties et qu'on était à
regrouper les partis serait peut-être
intéressant de voter pour quelqu'un mais
du coup là y'a personne qui meurt qui me
parle ce dimanche les bureaux de vote
seront ouverts de 8 heures à 20 heures